my name is no garden Schwartz and I
think you should listen to hot breath
because joel is a great guy in a great
comedian who I think is trying to do
something for the right reasons I think
he's genuinely interested in stand-up in
the craft and I think he's trying to
share wisdom from other people with
others who are interested in stand-up in
the craft so support his endeavors and
support comedy and thank you for
listening and watching
[Music]
[Music]
all right well I'll do an intro and then
we'll start and this waters for you as
well hey we've come a long way since
episode poor man you were episode four
how about it you you're episode what was
funny about yours is it was our first
phone interview and I remember the phone
kept cutting out the batteries died my
SD card filled up like all this happened
during our interview so it was a it was
a big lesson we learned no it'll be fine
I've interviewed a few people in here
right over there was Ian Edwards and
Robert Kelley and Roy Wood jr. was on
the couch I've been trying to move it
around so it looks like we're in
different places but it's really all
it's all the lobby let me just set a
timer so we make sure we get you but we
should be good nice all right so let me
give you your proper intro and then we
will begin all right
we're going off the grid for this one
[Laughter]
all right hot breath averse welcome back
to the hot breath podcast your weekly
guide to comedy mastering I am of course
your host Joel Byers and our guest today
hot brethren and sister and he was back
on the show in 2015
hopper episode number four back in that
day he had just been a new face on Just
for Laughs and just appeared on Last
Comic Standing since then he has been on
Conan twice he's been on James Corden
he's had his own Comedy Central special
and most recently he's been an actor and
writer on the marvelous miss Mazal and
the beautiful thing about that is in our
interview he actually alluded to wanting
to get more writing gigs and after
submitting countless writing packets to
different TV shows he actually booked
missus Mazal
because they saw his stand-up on Comedy
Central
so keep grindin on the stage kids all
your opportunities will grow from that
but let's see what opportunities grow
from this one they may see them on here
and want to book them for something else
but in the meantime no garnish warts
welcome back to hop breath man thank you
for having me I'd you the operation has
grown so much
not just migrant 2015 we did a phone
interview so when you asked me to do the
pot again and I had no idea we were now
live on YouTube so excuse the sweatpants
although if I'm being honest even if I
knew it was being filmed I still
probably would have worn the sweat pants
yeah like what I didn't know on camera
is this like is this the attire of like
a writer you guys just show up in like
pajamas and I honestly I've gone to work
in sweatpants before but I try to put on
jeans but I try to put it like some days
Navid we there's absolutely no dress
code but I try to be quasi respectful of
having a job what is it what is the job
of writing like I mean we had a Ian
Edwards on here and he's been in the
writers rooms for like decades but like
what is your experience been like in the
writers room my experience in the
writers room has been incredible but I
do have to preface it by saying that
every writers room is very different the
way every show operates is different so
like not just the experience of who you
work with but how that room operates it
really depends on who's running the room
and who you're writing for and with so
like our day is typically 9:30 10:00
a.m. to 6:00 seven o'clock okay so not
crazy hours like I've heard of some
writers rooms that go till 11 p.m. 2
a.m. on some nights doing rewrites and
stuff our writers room is pretty
respectful of our lives outside of it
like I still almost every night have
time to go and do sets after the show or
after after the day of work but it
really it boils down to like the way we
operate is we typically spend like the
first two months of and we have a very
long rise room we have like an eight
month room which is way long that's
above average yeah yeah I mean again it
varies but
my understanding most shows go for maybe
20 weeks and and we're close to 35 or 40
but we spend the first few months all in
the room together all day planning out
the season planning out the story arcs
for the episodes and the characters and
then once we go into breaking down
individual episodes that's when we spend
less time collectively and kind of go
off into our own offices to work on
whatever we specialize in for that
episode so it's like a very
collaborative effort from the start
again that then gets broken down into
different people doing their specialties
that's what's beautiful about missus
Mazal is like my wife and I got
instantly hooked and a big part of that
is the writing and when I had Beth
Stelling on here she talked about on
crashing they would almost just have
tent poles of like okay we want Pete and
his ex-wives boyfriend to end up in bed
together how that happens we don't know
but we like they would just set these
little like finish lines or checkpoints
to hit is that kind of how no are ours
is the opposite I sew I write with Amy
sherman-palladino and damn how do you
know who are the creators of the show or
also the head writers and they are
meticulous with their writing and one
thing that's different about our show
for most other shows is from what I
understand most other shows the writers
have to be there at the taping and at
the filming so if a line doesn't work
writers are there to pitch alts on our
show the actors and actors have to be
WordPerfect so like once the script is
finalized that's what they're saying
there's no like there's no this joke
isn't working can we get an alt it's
like no this is the joke save the joke
like our actors and actions don't miss
of of a but they are literally
word-for-word WordPerfect on our script
so there's no like there's dozens of
rewrites before the script is finalized
amongst ourselves but once that script
is out that's the script mm-hmm
how do you when you talked about you
first kind of beat out the season and
then you go into individual episodes is
it just looking at where we're starting
in this season where we want to end up
and then kind of reverse engineering it
like how do you build a story yeah I
mean it really comes down to
what are we trying to get accomplished
for the show and for each character you
know that a big lesson in writing in
general is just having a vision and like
if you know where you're planning on
going it makes everything else fall in
line much easier so obviously midge is
the main character in the show so her
story is the most important but there's
so many different pieces to her world
that you kind of map out every
characters journey and that's not to say
it's so rigid that like in week one
we're like this is what happens all
season for every character things change
within the realm of the season like what
we plan on happening episode five when
we are writing episode 1 might change
based on how we kind of reconfigure
things as we're going along but in
general you try to map out each
character's journey individually and
then what it means in the universe of
the show so that it can all kind of come
together and work off of each other and
how in terms of writing the show how
much is it bouncing ideas off verbally
versus actually like sitting down and
putting on the page there's a lot of
again we like because our show writers
in our show runners the Paladino z--
they're like legendary TV writers so for
people that don't know they met years
ago as writers on the original Roseanne
they've gone on they created the Gilmore
Girls dan was the showrunner for Family
Guy for a while so like these are these
are like classic TV writers who it's not
like a show where it's their first harad
and they're kind of feeling that like
they know exactly what they want they
know what they're doing and Amy is very
much a boss so it's like it's not one of
those writers rooms where everyone comes
in equally pitching's like we all shut
the [ __ ] up and listen to what Amy says
and then we listen to what Dan says and
then when they need us we feel it that
I've given this example one time before
I feel like our writers room operates a
lot like the Chicago Bulls during the
Jordan year so it's like you had Michael
Jordan you had Scottie Pippen that's Amy
and Dan I just have to be Steve Kerr you
know like when they pass me the ball I
need to hit the open jumper and we'll
win a championship I don't need to be
Michael Jordan I don't need to be
Scottie Pippen I just need to do my job
when they give me the opportunity to do
my job
so so I'm not in there trying to pitch a
million jokes a day it's just like I
listen to what they want and then when I
have ideas that are worth sharing I do
it and that a big lesson for the writers
room that I would say to aspiring
writers a lot of it is you're gonna be
spending 8 10 12 hours a day with these
people you need to learn how to get
along like personalities have to mesh
for a show to do well so as valuable as
it is to have good things to say it's
also very valuable to know when to shut
the [ __ ] up you know like writers rooms
are annoying if there's eight people in
there constantly trying to one-up each
other and get the funniest joke and
sometimes the biggest thing you can do
to advance your position in the room is
learning how to listen especially if
you're listening to people who are
smarter than you and better at you than
what you're trying to do do you have any
other tips for writers that's gold man
no I mean you know there's like all the
cliches of writing which are cliches for
a reason they're true like write what
you know draw on real experience show
don't tell little things like that all
matter but honestly a nugget of wisdom I
would say is like if you're ever
fortunate enough to be working with
great writers and people who have been
doing what you hope to do pay attention
like take advantage of the situation
don't be on your phone you know check in
Twitter and Instagram when like you
might be missing nuggets of wisdom that
will further your career from legendary
people around you and that's got to be
gratifying that you booked this writing
gig they saw your stand-up yeah and
we're like we've got to hire this guy
well it was gratifying on several levels
so first of all the show is about a
woman who ends up like kind of back
handedly falling into the world of
stand-up so they wanted stand-up
comedians in the room and so season one
I went in pretty much as a consultant
for the stand-up but I made myself
invaluable in the room because it's also
about a Jewish family and even though
Amy sherman-palladino his father was
Jewish he's not very religious doesn't
know a lot about it but the family were
writing about her like pretty observant
Jews and even though I was brought in to
help with the stand-up where I was the
biggest asset ended up kind of helping
with the Jewish religion stuff and
that's that's one of those things where
I grew up in a very religious home and I
was all
proud of being Jewish but as you can
imagine any kid being brought up with a
lot of religion like I was also kind of
resentful of having so much religion
forced upon me or like different things
that I couldn't do because I had to
observe the religion and then two three
decades later so much of my upbringing
became the exact reason why I succeed in
certain fields so it's like so cool you
never know when life experience that you
didn't necessarily appreciate growing up
will come into play and so it's like I
got this job and I'm thriving in this
job on a very successful show partly
because of Stan but also partly because
of the religious foundation my parents
gave me that I didn't even really
appreciate at the time mmm
your mother chose another another piece
of advice I would give to writers is
just like draw on your life experience
you never know exactly where that
experience is going to take you but like
be grateful for whatever upbringing
experience you have because that is what
adds to the voice that you can then
contribute to a project
so maybe advice for comics which is a
lot of this show a comic that's wanting
to get into a writers room what advice
do you have for how they can actually
get a seat at the table I mean honestly
it's it's luck meeting preparation you
know like you can have writing is
incredibly competitive so many people
want to do it and there's only a few
spots so so luck definitely plays a part
into it but when you're lucky enough to
have the opportunity you have to be
prepared for that opportunity which
means having your spec scripts having
your pilot scripts having something to
say you know so it's like you have to do
the work when no one's looking to be
ready when people are looking is what I
would say boom is mic drop and when you
say would you say you said have your
spec scripts have your pilot yeah the
tangibles they need yeah and you don't
and you don't know what necessarily
they're gonna ask for for those that
don't a spec script is when you write a
script of a show that exists so like if
you were to write your version of Modern
Family or whatever you know like you
write a 30-minute sitcom that people
already know
and what that does is it proves that you
can write for characters that already
exists it shows that you can mold your
voice to a voice of a show and fit in
cuz like if you get hired to write on
season four of a show that's already
been running those characters already
speak a certain way that world already
obviously operates in a certain way so
that's proven that your mind can mold to
the universe that's already built in
then a pilot script is your own original
idea and that shows where your voice
actually stands out and so those are two
key components of having samples but
again I got a very high end writing job
that's literally changed my life and
didn't even submit a writing packet that
came off of my standup and then more
importantly like stand-up is what got me
in the room with the Paladino x' but it
was my interview that got me the job and
that spoke more to what I was talking
about earlier just like personalities
meshing we just talked for two hours and
they could tell I was a person they
could tolerate being around every day in
a room mm-hmm
makes sense but how you write for
yourself and stand up and how you write
for these voices multiple actors on
screen like yes there how do you how do
you start it put it through a different
filters like that well it's been crazy
because it's not just writing for myself
versus multiple characters but I'm
writing for multiple characters who are
doing stand-up in the 60s so it's also
like a very different style it's like so
what was the question how do I do that
it's like you almost have to if okay I'm
writing for my own personal stand-up I
put it through this filter I'm writing
for a mid right now I put it through
this filter like you almost have to have
all these different voices going on your
head in a sense right yeah I mean that's
that's what part of the skill comes into
play like really good writers can write
for other people and I think for
stand-ups who are looking to get into
writing one skill that makes stand
stand-ups a great standup is being able
to open your eyes to other experiences
and being able to be empathetic or aware
of other viewpoints so that you can then
connect from your own viewpoint to there
so it's really a matter of stepping
outside yourself a little bit and
there's a lot of trial and error like I
submit a lot of jokes and a lot of
storylines that don't get accepted for
the show
and then a few do you know it's like you
got to take your shots and
just hope that you're putting quality
into any of the work that you put
forward and you submitted a lot of to a
lot of other shows before actually
booking them yeah and that's what was so
interesting is I submitted probably know
like twenty to thirty writing packets
over the years to other shows that I
always got to the second round or the
final round and then ultimately didn't
went out didn't get the job but that's
kind of what I was talking about of like
doing the work while no one is looking
to be prepared it's like if you really
want to be a writer then you have to be
willing to spend hours and days and
weeks and months doing packets for free
that might get you in the room in hopes
of one day hitting you know it's like
you can't be lazy with the [ __ ] if you
really want it then you got to be
willing to do it and and what that means
is doing it for free until someone is
willing to pay you and when it comes to
a spec script let's say you're
submitting to Modern Family
do you want to send a spec script about
Modern Family or at least the tangi no
yes no you do I mean again it's like the
rules have changed so much and they're
constantly dynamic so I don't want to be
giving advice that is right for one
person wrong for the other there's no
like concrete rules but from what I've
heard you don't want to send a script of
the show you're trying to write for to
that show partly because from a
liability standpoint if they were to end
up doing an episode down the road that
was similar to your idea they don't want
any kind of confusion or lawsuit of like
feeling like they stole your idea so you
want to send a spec script of another
show that everyone has seen because you
know it has to be a popular show so they
most likely know the characters in the
show you're writing for but it shouldn't
be the show you're trying to write for
because that's where there's like a
conflict of interest with ideas that
makes sense so maybe even transitioning
into your stand-up writing because
what's what's cool what's been cool
about doing this show and especially
Atlantica means like I mean I've seen
you at like open mics and now you're
like on Conan and like James Corden and
doing all this great stuff so your
stand-up writing was always something
that you were known for and just your
ability just to make humor out of really
just standing and delivering which you
still do yeah like there's no even you
you came up in urban rooms I came up in
urban rooms
and you never took the tip of like
exaggerating you always just hit them
right in the chest with it are you sure
I'm a shitty performer yeah I know I've
yeah I mean I've always been much more
writing I have confidence that my joke
is gonna hit as opposed to having to
oversell a bad pun sign or a bad premise
with a funny face yeah that's not my
style one of my favorite quotes from
your first interview with us was you
said a lot of your best jokes didn't
start out as funny they started out as
interesting yeah is that still true yeah
yeah I mean there's a million different
styles of coming my style is personal
90% of my act is talking about me or
what's going on in my life and so the
premises have to be coming from an
interesting place rather than a funny
place because it has to have stood out
to me in my own life like something that
happened as interesting or unique to
make me want to write about it yeah
mm-hmm and one of my favorite jokes I've
heard you recently was the subway joke
and you did not you did it on your most
recent conan episode Gordon yeah are you
doing on Corden yeah oh I was listening
to him this morning too and I guess I
just got them all mixed up in my head
no the Corden you did the wedding stuff
yeah yeah I'm telling you yeah you're
trying to tell me what I just did I'm
telling you it was Corden but what was
interesting about that though is JP at
Conan has been great to me he gave me my
first opportunities on late-night he's
awesome to work with so I would never
say a bad word about him but because I
had the door open at Conan I went to
Conan before I did court in the the set
was different cuz I hadn't like gotten
married yet so the stuff up top was
different but I had the subway joke and
when I wrote that joke I was like this
is a late-night joke and I sent it to JP
and JP was actually like I think that's
a great story in a longer set or like if
you ever do the couch on Late Night
that's a great bit but I don't think
that's good for a late-night stand-up
set and again no disrespect to JP he's
been amazing to me and he's great at
what he does so like but I I knew it was
a good late-night joke so that's just to
say like trust yourself as well where
even though a late-night Booker who have
worked with before whose judgment I
trust told me it wasn't a late-night
Joker's like
it is and I took it somewhere else and
it did really well on another late night
set so it's like always be willing to
listen to people who know better than
you but also like at the end of the day
trust yourself that mark Normand
actually said his I think it was his
first conan appearance they told him
like to take out one of the jokes cuz I
didn't think it would work and he did
the joke anyway yeah it killed
was it the puerto ricans thing man i
came here what he said it was yeah it
was like an example of it killed so ii
know what he's like he got off and said
anything cuz it worked right you know
it's yeah it's like by the time you're
doing late-night as a stand-up you've
done so much stand-up that you know what
works and that's not to say you know
better than the people who
professionally booked but it's like if
in your gut you know from your stand-up
experience doing it night in night out
especially with certain jokes like this
works and this is what it will work for
i knew the subway bit was a late night
joke and so because one late night
booker didn't want to put on their show
i found someone who would and what is
the preparation like for a show like
that cuz with Last Comic Standing you
had said you were like walking around
like going to the jokes in your head
like how meticulous had these late
nights well I mean the more experience
you get in comedy the more comfortable
you are I remember like the first time I
did Conan I was so nervous that I
couldn't enjoy it because it was Conan
and he was always my favorite because it
was my first late-night set I was
literally running the set over and over
and over in the back alleys of the
studio up until 10 minutes before I shot
him by the time I did Corden this is
three four years after my first
late-night said it was my third
late-night set and I'm just a much more
seasoned comedian in general so I was
like one of those things are just like
yeah I know the set it's five minutes
and I've been doing it so it's like
before you do a late-night set you
obviously want to have it nailed down
you have to have it down to a specific
timing of like under five minutes for it
to get approved for TV anyway so I ran
the set a lot that week or the two weeks
leading up to the show to make sure it
all fit but I didn't like wake up that
morning and recite the set 20 times to
myself I just kind of trusted that it
was
in my head I was like I know the set
this the set works I have faith in it I
know how to perform I know what late
night is like and so I just was way more
calm about it and had a great time doing
it
how did the two experiences compare like
doing a late night set on Conan versus
Corden they're actually they actually
were very different just in terms of the
setup like Corden and Conan as hosts
were both amazing they were both
incredibly kind to me
both Booker's JP and Ryan were awesome
to work with so like I had nothing but
positive experiences in terms of doing
the show with the intangibles outside of
actually performing what was different
about Conan and Corden is Conan is much
more like the big studio audience that's
30 feet away from you and Corden
actually has floor seats with crowd
members two feet away so I was actually
more comfortable performing on Corden
just because the literal setup of who
you perform to feels much more like a
comedy club there are people three feet
away from you like what happened in a
front row of a comedy club as opposed to
Conan very much feels like this is a
studio audience that you cannot reach
out and touch is there a teleprompter I
think shows they there's a teleprompter
that they offer you not word-for-word
they offer you to put your setlist on a
teleprompter in case you like blackout
they give you that option the first time
I did Conan I had it up there just cuz I
was so scared that I was gonna get out
there just completely blank the second
and third late night sets I didn't I
didn't want it because I didn't want to
have anything to take my eye off of the
audience and just like being in the
moment you know because I was like once
you know the teleprompter is there even
if you don't need it you kind of look at
it and I didn't want to throw me in the
middle of the performance so again that
came from being more comfortable and
knowing I was gonna remember my [ __ ] you
know I wasn't worried about it what
about backstage do you get like cool
gifts or is there food or like yeah back
there
Conan they give you I forget what it's
called but it's like a very famous
Chicago popcorn where it's a mix of
cheddar and caramel corn that's like
their stage gift and then there's all
kinds of just food in the grain room
available Gordon they ask
what I wanted in the green room and I
just said like fruit and vegetables cuz
I'm not trying to have like a turkey leg
before I go out national TV and then and
then there were some cool gift there's
like a whole lot I think it was a
sponsor there's like lotions and a face
mask that I gave to my wife and she was
thrilled with it the water bottle and a
mug and stuff like that but you're
obviously not doing it for the gift of
course but I don't even know what I'm
having them been backstage of a show
like that yet so I'm just curious is
like what it is yeah I can fly on the
wall yeah it's just a nice green room
where they give you a mirror and a couch
and but when when we've been in green
rooms that can literally be like the
closet right back at this restaurant
it's it's a proper no it's a dressing
room Oh another thing I would advise to
any stand-ups if you get your first late
night say I made the mistake my first
late night set of having a whole bunch
of friends in the room so like I had my
manager and then I brought like four or
five people to be in there and it ended
up being too much you know it was like I
was trying to go over my set I was
already nervous and there were people
talking like you don't want to bring
friends back there and be like everyone
shut the [ __ ] up so they were having a
good time and it was just kind of
distracting and now after that when I've
done it I served my wife and then I'll
have like my manager or my agent and
maybe one friend because they all like
Clayton came with me the second Conan
just cuz like it's good to have a
support system you don't want to sit
there alone but you also want to have a
small group of people who you're
comfortable being like hey guys can we
just kind of like be silent for a minute
so you can have your moment of peace you
know it's like you don't want to be too
overwhelmed before you go out you wanna
be able to concentrate and have your own
space do you get to meet did you meet
Corden or Conan before the Setter after
the set I met Conan the first time I
ever did Conan right before I went out
like I'm standing there at the curtain
it's the commercial break and that's the
most nerve-wracking because they'll tell
you like okay we just went to commercial
you're next and you just kind of stand
behind the curtain you can hear the the
like studio kind of shifting and right
before I went out and before we came
back from commercial break Conan came
and like shook my hand
and met me and that was awesome but it
was also like I was in my zone trying to
get ready to prepare for Conan and then
hear Conan come so I was like awesome to
meet him but also probably couldn't have
been worse timing because like because I
just like didn't want to meet Conan
right before I'm worried about like my
opening line the second time I had
already done it so like he didn't come
by the greenroom or anything but what
was cool it just so happened the second
time I did Conan was the night of their
holiday party because it was like middle
of December and he invited me to come to
the holiday party that night and that
night I went and actually got to hang
out with Conan and he could not have
been sweeter and more complimentary he's
just like a really good guy and then
Corden actually came and hung out in my
dressing room for five or ten minutes
before the show and I didn't even
realize what an impact I would have on
me but it actually made me so much more
comfortable like I didn't meet suit and
tie James Corden who was out in front of
studio audience he was just kind of
himself and he was just having a drink
shootin the [ __ ] and it was just like
way more casual and it made me feel much
better about going and performing on his
show so it was both both of them were
incredibly kind to me
so yeah they were great and let's let's
get into weeds a little bit on that
subway joke just because it is the most
recent late-night set not the Conan set
it was the cord and set but I'm glad you
remembered I do yeah you know I'm a fan
I'm a fan Noah and it's it's one of
those things that comedians strive to do
is here's a life experience happening
how can I make this a bit that's like
laughs laughs laughs laughs laughs
onstage so what was the evolution of
that well it's funny because literally
you know when something weird happens in
your life again whether it's interesting
or weird or whatever the joke isn't
fully formed but as soon as I saw this
do to flip out over onions at sunway at
Subway he left and I was like thank you
God Thanks I was like I just got three
minutes out of that I don't know how I
don't know where the joke is yet but
what I just saw is funny and I know
that's gonna be a joke and then from
there the first thing I did I took out
my phone hit the notepad and I didn't
try to write punchlines or jokes I just
wrote down everything I remember
happening I just hit the beats of the
event of like crazy guy flipping out the
things he said
and I wanted to mark it down accurate
like he really did say you know onions
are cheap if it's not free I don't wanna
he really did say I'd like to speak to
your manager all that [ __ ] because if I
could like remember the events correctly
then I could take my time to frame how I
want to phrase it to make it funny or
like what the reactions and kind of set
the scene so first I just hit the beats
and then for like the next two weeks I
kind of tried telling the story on stage
and I tried different punchlines and I
played around with different pacing
sometimes I tried to make it a short
quick joke sometimes I really tried to
drag it on and make it like a
seven-minute story and that's when I
found out places that like just weren't
funny that I had to cut and you know
it's it's the Goldilocks you know too
hot too cold eventually you just tinker
with it until it's just right and then
when it was just right I got on tape and
sent it in to Corden so when you're
talking about I was trying out these
different punchlines are you on the
paper like writing out the story and
trying to inject punchlines view more
onstage like just trying to repel the
story organically a little bit of both
like I would write out different lines I
wanted to try but then in the moment
would also possibly riff or feel it out
and and again it's just like it's about
being aware being comedians just about
being aware in the moment of when
something funny or interesting is
happening it's about being aware while
you're on stage with purpose whether you
wrote it out or whether you're riffing
like have the awareness on and offstage
to know what's working and also don't be
stubborn like the audience will let you
know if it's funny as you're working on
it's like if you have a joke that you
really believe in but certain parts of
it aren't working instead of trying to
force that part that's not working to
work try a new direction try a different
word try different pacing try different
inflection until you get consistent
results that are proving that you got it
right how many times will you try a joke
before you're like okay I guess it's
just not a joke or like a part of a joke
oh like a part of this story you're
talking about how many times have you
try something before - three times - and
then you kind of get a feel that maybe
yeah yeah yeah sometimes I'll even say a
joke and as I'm saying and I'm like oh
never mind
right and there's other times you're
like there's something here but there
are also the
also times when I've had something that
I wanted to do on stage whether it was a
premise or a line that I just couldn't
get to work and I put it away and forgot
about it in three years later it became
a great bit like what I did on my second
cone and the whole thing about like
Jesus from the Jewish perspective yeah
that was an idea I had in my notebook
for probably five years that I couldn't
get to work until one day I just figured
it out kind of out of nowhere but it's
like it's one of those things where as a
comedian we're always growing with life
experience so you never know what new
references or what new viewpoint might
naturally come to you just from life
experience
that'll suddenly be the key that unlocks
the joke so if something's not working
two times three times that doesn't mean
give up on it for good I mean maybe
sometimes sometimes just [ __ ] isn't
funny right yeah but but also like it's
okay to come back to something years
later because you have a whole new tool
set as a human being to possibly work
with it
what unlocked the subway joke was there
like an aha moment where like oh I
finally found like the premise of the
direction no so the subway joke was
unlocked from the beginning like that
that was just a funny thing I went oh
you know that was just dumb luck of
being a person out in the world seeing
to do flip out over a sandwich like that
was just the comedy God's giving me
three minutes by putting me in that
subway on that day but but it was like
two weeks of playing around with it to
where I got three minutes of that joke
that I really loved and then taking that
three minutes after I played with it and
stuck to what I thought was good and
doing it in different rooms like doing
it on a 10-minute bar show set in New
York doing it on a 45-minute set in
Dayton Ohio at a funny bone and like
realizing that it works coast-to-coast
comedy club two bars show it's just a
funny joke and then from there having
the confidence to be okay this is
clearly universally funny and I have the
punches in the right place where where
were most of the punches come from is it
the details are there any embellishments
I mean not in bed I really didn't
embellish his behavior the details would
be in my responses that I got and that's
where you have the luxury
taking them up in your own time later on
we're like in that joke where he says
you just lost a customer he really
didn't say that of course in the moment
I wasn't thinking like dude their
spokesman was Jared but that's one where
like I got to sit with it for a week and
be like okay what about the subway
universe is funny what references can I
make and I was like people think about
Subway what's one of the most infamous
parts about Subway
unfortunately that their spokesman was a
[ __ ] pedophile you know that's like
how can I work that in tastefully
because I also it's like you work in
Jared all of a sudden what was a really
funny joke about a dude losing his [ __ ]
over a sandwich becomes a pedophilia
joke and that's a whole different darker
direction that was not the point of the
joke so that's again we're like finding
little ways to tinker with it where you
can make a Jared reference because it's
synonymous with Subway without it
dominating the joke and going in a whole
different direction and so that's where
like you say embellishments or add-ons
it's like that's where the time and the
shadows as we're writing in your
notebook or figuring it out on stage
comes into play of just tinkering with
little things here or there to find the
right mixture and I like you were saying
how okay this happened at Subway what
when I think of Subway what all do I
think of it's like what else can I
associate with in the joke right that
kind of your strategy there yeah it's
just it's just being creative or even
the opening line where I was like this
guy flipped out of the subway and to be
clear I'm talking about the sandwich
shop not the underground train because
in New York if you say subway people are
thinking about the Train so yeah it's
just like playing with language playing
with the world that's built in like most
things have a certain connotation in
people's minds so you have to be aware
of that as well as like when I bring
this up where's their mind naturally
gonna go and then from there where can I
take that that's gold
and was the kid was was he kind of an
addition to kid at the subway yeah that
was pretty was like us like yeah I mean
yeah and that that was also part of what
was built in funny where I just lucked
out is like not only was i fortunate
enough to witness this psychopath
flipping out over a sandwich but I also
got to witness it happening to a
teenager who couldn't have cared less
you know so I was like that world of
contrasts it's entirely possible that
the joke wouldn't have been funny like
if that guy would have flipped out and
it was enough
they're older guy making the sandwich
who flipped out back then maybe it's a
vicious argument maybe that was funny or
maybe it's not and and I leave subway
without a jokes I'm like what the [ __ ]
did I just see but the contrast of this
dude's angry energy versus an employee
who couldn't have cared less I was like
that's hilarious and he did he actually
say I'm coming back the next morning
yeah
oh okay yeah he really did ask like when
were your manager be back and the kid
really did say like 8 a.m. and I don't
know if the kid was just being a dick or
if subway does open at 8 a.m. but again
that's where like later the
embellishment of course I didn't take
out my phone and set my alarm but like
that's where I was like okay what's
funny about this guy coming back at 8
a.m. and then how can I implant myself
in the joke to get an additional
punchline whether it happen or not and
that's where the whole part of setting
my phone and and also again that's like
playing with the language playing with
society the reason my line about setting
the alarm for 7:30 is funny is because
when I say and that's when I finally
took out my cell phone people assume I'm
about to talk about videotaping this guy
losing his [ __ ] or putting it on
Instagram and I went in a different
direction no one's thinking I'm gonna
set my alarm to come see him flip out on
the manager the next morning so it's
like you know just be creative and how
yeah and it is kind of how you said it
like in that pace as well to where
you're saying up the expectation that
oh he's gonna film this but it's
actually right and and that again it's
like when I was talking about with Jared
of like okay I take out my cell phone in
people's minds they're thinking I'm
gonna film it now where can I take them
in a direction they weren't expecting
boom misdirect you know and finding the
sometimes the hardest part of a joke is
like ending it like how can I end on a
laugh was his closure yeah well well the
the the hardest part about comedy it
kind of like how I was talking about in
in a writers room does the skillset of
knowing what to say and the skillset of
knowing when to shut the [ __ ] up in a
joke there's a skillset of knowing when
to add punchlines and there's a skillset
of knowing when the joke is over like
one of the worst things comedians can do
is over tag a joke and take something
that was hilarious and make it unfunny
because they couldn't stop trying for
more and more like don't be selfish with
the laughs if you have a great punchline
no one to step away and just let it be
and how did you find because it ends
with like I'll have an onion sandwich
yeah
callback yeah it says
and I noticed that I'm watching your set
last night as well like you're good at
kind of just slipping in those callbacks
at different times it's very clever
so was that when did you come up with
the the button of it that I'll have an
onion sandwich was that in early on or
was that something you were trying to
figure out no I that was probably a week
or two in of testing with it like I had
played with it and I think I think I
probably had a few iterations of like
that wasn't even necessarily the ending
but it's again just playing with it on
stage seeing what gets a good final
laugh a clever callback and just
realizing that is the natural end of
that joke that's where I want to end
that story and how important is it to
understand like the premise or like what
is this joke about and I'm selfishly
asking this as well because when I when
I got married I cried a lot and I got
booed by my efficent like all this
happened and I'm like this is hilarious
and I have yet to make it translate to
stage well I mean I guess it's important
to know what you're trying to highlight
for the humor but when you talk about
like what is this joke about you know
that depends on the joke like sometimes
there are jokes where you're trying to
make a greater point like there are some
jokes that you really are trying to be
philosophical or like shed light on
something that's important to you and
there are some jokes that are just jokes
and you don't have to make it deeper
than it is so it's like the subway joke
is not like a microcosm of the working
man's struggle against a power dilemma
with an angry man who has power because
of capital it was like know as a [ __ ]
psychopath who ordered a sandwich and
I'm not making it deeper than that you
know yeah your joke about crying at the
wedding that that's loaded because it's
like weddings hold a lot of value the
idea of a man not being able to cry you
know like there is something separate
from being funny there is like social
commentary on like what you got booed
for crying but it's the most important
day of your life so like why wouldn't
you cry oh because you're a man you're
not allowed to cry at your own wedding
like there's something beyond just being
funny about that but I also wouldn't
waste time like overthinking you know I
would say write the joke like whatever
naturally jumps out to you about it
being funny because there's also
something about funny about you being
booed at your wedding separate for
like that's the thing is like on one
hand it's about a man crying in the
commentary on that but on the other hand
it's just about like a groom getting
booted his wedding for whatever reason
find out where the agreement between
those two principles are I would say
yeah because the misdirect I have right
now is that I was crying be kind of set
up how terrible wedding planning is and
then the misdirect is I started crying
because I realized the wedding planning
was over and that's really as far as
it's gotten that's funny I would I would
try maybe something about like there's
also something about they're booing you
because you're crying which made you cry
harder but for a different reason like
first you were crying tears of joy and
now you're crying because you're being
booed at your wedding that was hurtful
you know like there's a million ways to
explore and play around with it and see
what feels best coming from you it also
has to be in your voice right you know
so like it depends on the jokes you told
before that it depends on the jokes you
plan on telling you after because
everything sets the stage you know like
if you're doing a longer set all jokes
aren't attached and related but they do
all affect how they're received by the
audience like the order of the jokes you
tell matter you know like I have I just
got married and I have certain jokes
about marriage and about my wife that I
can't tell until the end of my set
because I need to make sure the audience
likes me up top so they'll go with me on
this ride of potentially inappropriate
or like offensive stuff because they
already know it's coming from a good
silly place you know so it's like the
order of your jokes in the order of how
you set your set up matters because the
way people perceive you going into the
joke will affect how they interpret it
as you say yeah I have noticed that like
I have a joke about like shopping at
Goodwill and then I have a joke later on
about a job paying $8 an hour and that
it should include drugs yeah and I
noticed when I do the goodwill
beforehand it sets up the expectation
that he's cheap or he's always trying to
like save money however he can so when
it should include drugs it hits harder
because they have the context that oh he
shops a goodwill it was all about saving
money yeah everything matters you know
and it's like I'm not I'm not like an
edgy comic who's out there
offensive [ __ ] but I have a few jokes
with some bite in it and I usually save
those for later in the set when I have
earned good will not good but like when
I've earned when I've earned the
audience's trust because they know it's
like coming from a playful place because
they've had 30 minutes of other jokes to
set the stage of who I actually am going
into those jokes are you disciplined and
do you write every day no no no I reckon
I write when I'm inspired to write okay
so like I've never been the kind of
person that can write from 6 to 8
o'clock or from 10:00 to 2:00 like I
can't write on a schedule I can only
write when I'm inspired but because of
that I respect it over everything so
like no matter what I'm doing when I
have an idea I made sure to stop and
write it yeah and you said in the first
interview like you honor that idea yeah
by taking the time direct whether it's 2
p.m. or 2 a.m. honor that idea and write
it down
yeah and that's that's the same like my
process hasn't changed and that I can't
I can't force when I'll be creative but
when the creativity comes I prioritize
that over everything so now that you're
at this point in your career where the
this you've been working on like and we
talk about show business you've been
working hard on the show but now that
the business is picking up as well and
it would be interesting I just I just
read about you and Clayton whoo
Clayton's been on here a few times as
well Clayton English but it's it's funny
you guys like started together and now
you're getting to work on a show
together we were joke I cancelled the
show got canceled
yeah because of the the Turner Time
Warner merger and and you know that was
an important lesson in show business
that wasn't a new lesson there are ups
and downs in this business and you take
it all in stride but yeah so for those
who don't know Clayton and I first we
had a pilot order like first of all to
sell an idea for a show and even get a
pilot order it's such a difficult thing
then for that pilot to get shot it's
such a difficult thing and then for that
pilot to get shot off of an idea you
sold and then get picked up in order to
series is probably a one-in-a-million
worst chance so like that happened
Clayton and I sold an idea the pilot got
shot we sold the show and it got ordered
the series series pickup Clayton and I
were going to be hosting an executive
producing our own show that got ordered
for 10 episodes which is like unreal and
we were gonna do it in Atlanta which was
unreal because this is where we started
and and then three weeks into the
writers room they cancelled the show
because and this and this is one of
those things where like no wrongdoing of
our own truTV who had bought and ordered
our show at that time truTV is Turner
Turner got in a merger bought out by
Time Warner and the new executives from
Time Warner fired all the people from
true that were responsible for our show
like all the people from true that
ordered our pilot and then ordered to
series lost their jobs and the new
regime from Time Warner didn't want to
be responsible for a show that they had
nothing to do with creating or picking
up so is like Clayton and I did nothing
wrong and it wasn't even that the people
from Time Warner it's not like they saw
the pilot we're like oh no this isn't us
they were just like it's not ours clean
house we want nothing to do with it and
so the show got cancelled and and that's
one of those things were sobs and downs
of show business like one minute you
have a dream coming true and then the
next minute it's just gone what was that
like did you have like you like oh this
is like fate this is culminating we're
friends we're shooting in Atlanta was
there that moment of like we did it and
then well of course I was initially
disappointed but I also I truly felt
like it was a weird blessing in disguise
like first of all clean and I both had
the good fortune of having other things
going on so it wasn't like this was our
one shot you know I was like I'm still
working on Mazal I knew I was going back
for season three so it's not like I was
suddenly unemployed with nowhere to go
Clayton's comedy and acting is killing
it so it's not like it's not like this
was our baby and if this got snatched
away we were suddenly on the streets
with no money again like we were very
lucky to be in a position our careers
where this was one of a few things we
were doing which was which was helpful
just financially and and egotistically
speaking and then what I've noticed in
this business is like opportunities come
and go you have to learn how to react to
the wins and the losses all the same
because they're both going to happen and
you know it's that whole like god
[ __ ] close the door opens a window
where like I don't know what the next
thing is but I do know that whatever my
next project or my next opportunity is I
wouldn't have been available for if this
show didn't get cancelled like missus
Mazal I had submitted three different
packets for shows I really wanted to get
hired for that I did not get hired and
then if I did get hired for those I
would not have been available to submit
for mrs. Mazal which ended up literally
changing my life and became a Golden
Globe and Emmy award-winning show
whereas those other shows I wanted to
get hired on are all canceled so like
you don't know where the next
opportunity's gonna come from you don't
know where the next blessing is coming
from and if you're gonna be in this
business you have to be tough enough to
take it all in stride [ __ ] is gonna get
picked up shit's gonna get cancelled
you're gonna have great shows you're
gonna have bad shows but if you're all
doing it for the love of the art the
love of the game and you're working hard
if you're talented and hardworking
things will line up and fall into place
SIA woo Noah that's gold man thank you
so much for doing my pleasure thank you
for having me this has been amazing it's
cool just to see comics you know because
we've had like Dulce Sloane on here
who's you know like it's just cool to
see all these comedians in the arc of
their career where it is like you're you
start comedy with these aspirations and
it's like oh you're like doing them yeah
it's been wild to see a lot of the
people we all came up with like my
generation of Atlanta comics are all
killing it and all across the board you
know there's like there's a lot of us
doing very well in the mainstream and
corporate route of show creation and TV
and then you got people like Carlos who
is arguably the most famous comic on the
underground like 85 south and what
Carlos is doing is mind-blowing and it's
all on something he built on his own so
you know there's no right or wrong way
to do it there's no one way to do it
just do it just do it
well before we get out of here man I
know you got a you got to take a nap in
your pajamas here but that was my
attempt at a dig which I just reminded
me I and thinking of the opportunities I
remember roasts battle came here and
taped and I went against Dulce and I was
like oh
Comedy Central here we go but then they
cut out our part yeah and that was a
moment
and I didn't tell anyone I was on either
cuz I heard I think Andy Sanford was the
first person who told me he had a moment
where he's like oh this is it and then
it didn't happen I was like I'm never
saying anything yeah so that just
reminded me of like taping roast battle
here and then it not airing and I was
just like you know what I'm actually
grateful my TV debut wasn't like on Rose
babble yeah in hindsight yeah I mean a
lot of times things that you wanted in
the moment looking back you can realize
it's a good thing it didn't happen
mm-hmm well I'm glad this happened and
thanks for taking the time man thank you
for having me always a pleasure speaking
with you before we get out of here is
there anything else you want the world
to know know what when is this coming
out I don't know yet it'll be a couple
weeks okay well if this comes out before
December 6 season three of mrs. maislin
premieres on Amazon Prime so check out
mrs. nasal I just released my second
album two months ago so if you're into
my comedy albums called white men can't
joke just to play on white men can't
jump which is one of my favorite movies
you can get that on itunes amazon
spotify anywhere that you stream Pandora
listen to my albums watch the show I
noticed this on YouTube as well that's
someone putting it on YouTube which we
don't really yeah and by all means got
like I don't give a [ __ ] about album
sales I see like a penny of every it
doesn't matter to me like I just want
people to hear the joke so if you want
to go watch it on YouTube for free by
all means I support that too yeah cuz
I've heard like spins on Sirius can be a
good supplemental income for comics yeah
I mean you know it's all great but there
there's nothing more valuable than just
gaining new fans so it's like the ten
cents I might get from Sirius XM versus
someone who might come to a show because
they listen to it for free and liked it
that that means more to me is so however
you can access my material try to
support it and it's Noah G comedy comm
all social medias Noah G comedy correct
all right and that the final thing if
you don't mind looking in the camera and
let the people know who you are and why
they should listen to hot breath my name
is no garden Schwartz and I think you
should listen to hot breath because Joel
is a great guy in a great comedian who I
think is trying to do something for the
right reasons I think he's genuinely
interested in
stand up in the craft and I think he's
trying to share wisdom from other people
with others who are interested in stand
up in the craft so support his endeavors
and support comedy and thank you for
listening and watching all right no
gardens for snakes being a hot breath oh
man
[Music]
[Music]